destroying the social media app parlor
and ripping it off the internet was a
team effort it took more than simply
amazon and
apple and google amy pickoff is a chief
policy officer there at parlor she joins
us
to tell us which other companies were
involved in this historic
attack on free speech and our civil
liberties because you should know their
names
amy it's great to see you tonight thank
you for coming on i'm sorry parlor is
still
not up as i'm sure our viewers know tell
us if you would because we want to know
who they are
who participated in this attack
on the first amendment and on your
company
hi tucker thanks um so other companies
that were involved were
twilio who dropped us we are also
having issues with a captcha using any
sort of a captcha
in our program fleury dropped us
there's also people that you weren't
really aware of unless you were into the
tech
the people who actually connect you to
the internet and provide nodes and the
hosts who domain hosts etc and those are
the people on the tech side that i'm not
as aware of but there are a number
of people involved and whether they're
all working together or whether they're
all just caving into the same
cancel culture pressure obviously at
parlor we do think that we were singled
out
unfairly because this content that
nobody
wants on anywhere on their platforms
this inciting content that is wrong
was unfortunately everywhere as you've
read in stories this week from the
washington post and elsewhere
i i assume most of them are just greedy
soulless little robots who will do
whatever it takes to
continue to loot the country it's not
like they have an ideological agenda
whether they have agenda or not here's
you know one of the things that i think
is going on at least with the the bigger
tech companies you know you talk people
been talking about collusion
is there collusion involved but what if
the truth is actually
a lot worse and that parlor is just the
latest casualty
in a sort of faustian bargain that big
tech has made
with status government and by this i
mean that
big tech has made itself dependent on
immunity
with respect to its two major prongs for
monetization that it depends on
so one of them is this content
moderation removing pieces of content
they have immunity for that
under section 230 and that also includes
the curation of feeds and the algorithms
that they use to do that that increase
engagement
those are all just immune from scrutiny
and from liability
and then the second of course is the
data pillaging as we like to call it
at parlor we don't believe that you
should be making money by
monetizing personal data of people
and both of those things have become
part of this bargain i don't know if you
saw the wall street journal piece
it was the big tech versus the
constitution saved the constitution from
a big tech
and they talked about the fact that the
immunity of 230
when combined with the pressure from
people
in congress telling facebook and telling
twitter that they need to remove more
hate speech and do more about
misinformation
this is in effect censorship by proxy
and then with respect to data if you
look at the consent decree between
united states
and facebook the ftc and facebook from
last year
you could see in that that facebook was
allowed to continue
its data mining practices that help
you know monetize it and at the same
time maybe the ftc and the doj
can get backdoors into data under the
terms of that consent decree
this is a very cozy relationship that i
think is very disturbing
and parlor's model doesn't depend on
either of those things
cozy doesn't even describe it i mean
it's scary it's really scary
apple helped write our current
immigration law
some of the liberal children in the what
current white house
considered giving the presidential medal
of freedom to tim cook of apple
who hates the white house and the
country i would i was able to tell
i was going to tell you that with
respect to this particular fight i see
apple as an ally i don't know if you saw
that tim cook
has said that parlor could come back on
to the app store
after we improve our content uh
excuse me content moderation so oh thank
you tim cook i'm really great i'm glad
well hopefully he'll wake up in a good
mood tomorrow and grant us that favor
who made these people god anyway i mean
what what world is this where tim cook
gets to decide but see
at least they stand for privacy tucker
at least they stand for privacy
yeah well amy i appreciate you coming on
tonight thank you
thank you